What's next for Spider-Man after "No Way Home?"
While we don't know that, we might be able
to get some hints by looking back at Peter
Parker's MCU journey from the beginning.
Here's the entire Spider-Man MCU story explained.
Surprisingly, Peter Parker's first appearance
in the MCU doesn't come in "Captain America:
Civil War."
Instead, that honor goes to "Iron Man 2,"
where Tony Stark saves a little kid during
the climax of the film.
While Tony's flying in to stop Ivan Vanko
from using weaponized Hammer drones to attack
the attendants at the Stark Expo, a young
boy in an Iron Man mask raises his toy gauntlet
to stop one of the drones before getting some
help.
"Nice work kid."
Fans have long speculated that the masked
child was actually a young Peter Parker, years
before Marvel got the go-ahead from Sony to
officially add Spider-Man to the MCU.
After all, the Stark Expo takes place in Queens,
and Peter is a long-time science geek who
wouldn't miss the opportunity to go to an
event like that.
Tom Holland told The Huffington Post in 2017
that as far as he and MCU head honcho Kevin
Feige are concerned, that unnamed boy is definitely
Peter Parker.
No wonder Peter Parker grows up to have so
much hero worship for Tony Stark in the modern-day
MCU.
By the time Spider-Man: Homecoming hit theaters,
audiences had seen Peter's Uncle Ben die on
the big screen twice in two different franchises—three
times if we count the new perspective on the
murder portrayed in "Spider-Man 3"—so it's
no wonder that the filmmakers of "Spider-Man:
Homecoming" chose to skip over that particular
part of Spider-Man's origin story.
That said, there's been enough hints and references
to make it clear that the MCU version of Peter
definitely had an Uncle Ben that he lost at
some point.
In "Spider-Man: Far From Home," Peter's luggage
looks second-hand and bears the initials "BFP."
The luggage almost certainly belonged to one
Benjamin Franklin Parker before Peter used
it.
According to "Spider-Man: Homecoming" writers
Jonathan Goldstein and John Francis Daley,
an earlier draft of the film would have seen
Aunt May explicitly mention her dearly departed
husband.
With all that, we can peg Uncle Ben's death
at around six months before the events of
"Captain America: Civil War," since that film
shows Peter telling Tony that he's had his
powers for "six months."
Peter even indirectly mentions that he blames
himself for Uncle Ben's so-far mysterious
death by saying that,
"When you can do the things I can, but you
don't, and then the bad things happen, they
happen because of you."
In other words, with great power comes great
responsibility.
In 2015's "Ant-Man," Scott Lang's titular
tiny hero runs afoul of Sam Wilson, The Falcon,
while sneaking into Avengers' headquarters.
Naturally, it leads to the two superheroes
battling each other in the classic Marvel
style.
Although neither hero walks away the obvious
victor, Scott gains the device he's after
and something else that he wasn't expecting:
Sam Wilson's respect.
At the end of the film, Scott's friend Luis
tells him that his cousin Ignacio met this
"crazy fine writer chick" who actually knows
Falcon.
And in Luis' summation of the conversation,
we learn that Sam's been looking for Ant-Man.
While he was looking for one bug-themed superhero,
he very nearly finds another,
"We got a guy who jumps, a guy who swings,
a guy who crawls up the walls."
There are plenty of superheroes in the Marvel
Universe who jump and swing around the city,
but there's only one wall-crawler that casual
fans would be likely to recognize.
In conjunction with his appearance in "Captain
America: Civil War," we can infer that Spidey
started operating as an official local superhero
during the events of "Ant-Man," even if the
bigger media outlets hadn't yet noticed him.
Six months after Peter gets his powers, Tony
drops by Aunt May's apartment to meet the
mysterious, arachnid-themed superhero who's
been showing up on YouTube.
Iron Man adds him to his team of Avenger-hunting
Avengers, as part of his ongoing effort to
take down Bucky.
So Peter heads to Berlin, does some sightseeing,
and annoys Tony Stark's bodyguard and pal,
Happy Hogan.
Then he gets a costume upgrade courtesy of
Tony Stark, and fights against Captain America's
team.
Spider-Man acquits himself nicely in the fight,
briefly trapping Falcon and the Winter Soldier,
and even helping Iron Man and War Machine
take down a giant Ant-Man.
However, the fight ends with Tony's best friend,
Rhodey, wounded by friendly fire.
As for Peter, he suffers a pretty frightening
fall, although he ultimately emerges unscathed.
After the events of "Captain America: Civil
War," Peter heads back to Queens with his
new, more technologically advanced Spider-suit.
Tony tells Peter that the Avengers will "let
him know" if there are any future missions,
and in the meantime, he should go to school
and focus on being a local hero.
Two months later, while swinging around on
his after-school crime-fighting rounds, he
accidentally interrupts an ATM heist organized
by crooks who are using high-tech weapons.
After a phone call report with Happy goes
ignored, Peter follows up on the weapons dealers
and gets into a fight with their leader, the
Vulture.
Tony sends a drone to bail Peter out and give
him yet another talking to about how Peter
should stop trying to fight supervillains.
Peter half-listens — mostly to the parts
about how his suit has a ton of capabilities
that he didn't know about — and gets his
buddy Ned to hack the suit and give him full
access.
Round two with the Vulture in Washington,
D.C. ends with Peter trapped in a warehouse
for the night, and when he heads off for round
three on a ferry ride in New York, it turns
out that Iron Man and the FBI had organized
a sting operation that Peter inadvertently
interrupts.
Disappointed in his protégé, Tony takes
back the suit, and Peter recommits to his
regular life and asks his crush, Liz, to prom.
Unfortunately, Liz's dad is the Vulture, forcing
Peter to take him down in his original low-tech
suit before the winged villain can steal a
ton of valuable Stark tech.
Spider-Man succeeds, Vulture goes to prison,
Liz moves to Oregon with her mom, and Tony
offers Peter a place on the Avengers roster
if he wants.
Instead, Peter turns him down, choosing to
focus on being a friendly neighborhood Spider-Man
for a while.
Peter's decision to stay close to the ground
and look out for the little guy lasts about
as long as it takes to watch the credits for
"Spider-Man: Homecoming."
When Thanos' Black Order invade Earth in search
of the Infinity Stones in "Avengers: Infinity
War," Spider-Man hops right in to help in
defending Earth.
Dr. Strange is kidnapped by the Black Order's
Ebony Maw, and Peter chases after him, hitching
a ride on the Maw's spaceship before it flies
away completely.
Tony quickly joins him and provides Spidey
with the even more high-tech super suit last
seen at the end of "Homecoming."
Spidey and Iron Man free Dr. Strange, blast
Ebony Maw out into space, and land on Titan,
Thanos' home planet.
They're quickly joined by some of the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
The heroes prep to fight Thanos, who soon
arrives to take Dr. Strange's Time Stone to
add to his Infinity Gauntlet.
The heroes put up a valiant effort, but their
plan goes awry, and Thanos teleports to Earth
after nabbing the Time Stone.
Soon after, he gets the Mind Stone from Vision,
puts it all together, and snaps his fingers,
causing half of all life in the universe to
fade away.
Unfortunately, Peter's 50/50 probability comes
out on the negative side, and he turns to
dust in Tony's arms on an alien planet.
"I don't know what's happening, please I don't
wanna go, I don't wanna go."
After Thanos kills off half of the universe,
the remaining half are left to mourn their
fallen friends and family.
Unfortunately for Peter, it doesn't seem like
there are many left to remember him.
For the five years between Thor killing Thanos
in the beginning of "Avengers: Endgame" and
when Captain America gets the gang back together,
it seems like the only one left to mourn Peter
is Tony Stark.
He even keeps a framed picture of his young
protégé in the kitchen of his cabin home.
Luckily for Spider-Man, Tony eventually feels
guilty enough to rejoin the Avengers.
Once he's back on the team, The Avengers head
back in time to steal the Infinity Stones
before Thanos could destroy them in the present
timeline, and reconstruct another Infinity
Gauntlet.
And with one snap of Hulk's mighty hand, the
dusted half of the universe is restored exactly
how they were when they disappeared.
Thanos from a previous timeline heads to the
present in order to re-snap everything into
oblivion, but every superhero or superhero-adjacent
character stands in his way — including
Spider-Man.
Peter joins the fight, meets some of his new
superhero peers, and then watches as Tony
Stark gives his life to dust Thanos' crew
with a snap of his own.
After all that space alien craziness, it's
back to normalcy for everyone's favorite wall-crawler
in "Spider-Man: Far From Home."
With his schoolmates recovering from, ya know,
being dead for five years, Peter joins a class
trip to Europe.
He's looking forward to a relaxing vacation
to decompress from — all of that — and
maybe confess his burgeoning romantic feelings
for MJ.
Instead, he's quickly embroiled in a fight
against multiversal Elementals alongside Nick
Fury, Maria Hill, and the superhero from another
universe, Quentin Beck, aka Mysterio.
To make things worse, Peter's struggling to
live up to Iron Man's legacy, a job that seems
all the more difficult when he receives a
pair of high-tech sunglasses from Tony that
give the young hero control over a ludicrous
amount of information and technology.
Desperate for a mentor, Peter gives up his
sunglasses to Beck, whose magic powers and
big brother attitude seem to make him a better
successor to Tony than Peter could ever hope
to be.
Unfortunately, Beck's running a con on Peter
and Nick Fury; he's not magic, he's not from
another world, and he's definitely not a superhero.
Peter learns the truth and eventually defeats
Mysterio, with the villain seemingly dying
in the final battle.
Spidey returns to New York having saved the
day once again, and everything seems to be
going well.
Until, that is, J. Jonah Jameson of TheDailyBugle.net
leaks Mysterio's dying confession and reveals
to the entire world that…
"Spider-Man's name is Peter Parker."
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" picks up right where
"Spider-Man: Far From Home" leaves off.
Peter and MJ are in the middle of New York,
trying to digest that Peter's secret identity
has been revealed to the world.
Peter hopes this will all die down, but he
is shocked to see his home surrounded by the
press.
It's not long before the Department of Damage
Control arrests him and interrogates MJ, Ned,
and Aunt May.
However, thanks to ace attorney Matt Murdock,
aka Daredevil, the charges are dropped.
Peter even goes back to school, where he's
met with a mixed response.
Peter tells MJ and Ned that they just need
to ride this out for a few months until they
graduate and all go to MIT together.
Unfortunately, the controversy leads the college,
and every other college they applied to, to
reject the trio outright.
This leads to a crazy plan.
Peter initially approaches Doctor Strange
and asks him to go back in time, so he could
prevent Mysterio from ruining his friends'
lives.
Strange offers a spell instead that would
make people forget that Peter Parker was Spider-Man.
The spell proceeds, but Peter can't leave
well enough alone, constantly interrupting
Strange as he casts the spell to add a number
of exceptions.
The spell goes awry, but Strange seems to
contain it.
However, the spell wasn't totally contained.
While trying to talk a representative from
MIT into changing her mind, Peter is attacked
by Dr. Octopus, the villain from "Spider-Man
2."
When a Pumpkin Bomb appears, Strange teleports
Peter back to his Sanctum.
Somehow, Peter has started drawing in people
from other multiverses that know his identity.
Strange sends him to track them down.
Peter captures Electro, the villain from "The
Amazing Spider-Man 2," as well as the Sandman,
from "Spider-Man 3."
Strange captures the Lizard, and the tortured
Norman Osborn accepts Peter's help.
Strange plans to send them back to their realities,
but things soon got more complicated.
Aunt May convinces Peter that the captured
villains need help and he can't simply send
them off to die.
He succeeds with Doctor Octopus, but Norman
Osborn reverts to being the Green Goblin and
persuades the others to once again target
Peter.
As the villains scatter, the Goblin kills
Aunt May, leaving Peter a wreck.
"This is all my fault.
I can't save everyone."
In searching for Spider-Man, Ned uses Strange's
Sling-Ring and accidentally finds the Andrew
Garfield version from "The Amazing Spider-Man."
Trying again, Ned locates the Tobey Maguire
version from the original "Spider-Man" series.
The two Spider-Men track down Holland's Peter,
and give him a pep talk.
Afterwards, the trio of Spider-Men draw the
villains into a battle at the State of Liberty
in an effort to cure them once and for all.
It almost works out, but The Green Goblin
reappears and destroys the apparatus that
contains Strange's botched spell.
The multiverse starts cracking open as Peter
has to be restrained from killing the Goblin.
He gets the cure, but Peter is left with a
terrible decision.
To save the world, Peter has to let Doctor
Strange cast the spell again, this time with
no exceptions.
Peter says goodbye to Ned and MJ, and vows
to track them down and make them remember
him.
When the time comes, however, Peter can't
do it.
He sees MJ and Ned both make it into MIT.
Having finally learned the importance of responsibility,
Peter gets his own apartment and continues
his career as Spider-Man with an uncertain
future.
There's one last loose end, however.
Eddie Brock, rather than joining in on any
of the conflict, spends his time on the MCU's
Earth at a bar.
Just before the spell pulls him back into
his universe, he leaves a single drop of the
Venom symbiote in the MCU reality.
With the announcement of another sequel in
development, this extradimensional visitor
may well become a problem for Holland's Spider-Man...
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.